don't you have to go to work today I
gotta grab some stuff and get out to the
site where you are late hoping that what
are you doing over them you are to
listening at rear gym
he did some bad things I did some bad
things Tommy we thought we were helping
they didn't work out that way they
always worried too much Jim the pastas
the pause my friend you keep a diary of
the horror we created you never happened
that's the way you want to play with me
you did your part I didn't mind we all
found a way to justify it keep you guys
hoping my friend it's the ones who are
after the to you in the end
what's going on chicken
a company's clearinghouse you'll have
two weeks potion is the one short you go
I recorded everything I'm gonna throw it
out right Laurel can see it really for
Joe we have a surprise for she's a
remarkable woman I gotta go Stan you
hear me I got to go
you ever have one of those days when
everything's going wrong and everybody
wants to kill you for something
I could see the company's perspective
you're the last real threat on the table
then we got nothing left to talk about
[ __ ] is that